The effect of music on the brain is just
incredible right now. If I put you in a
state where I can play you a good
rhythm, I can tell you anything you
want.
>> That message is being put in their brain
and it just bypass, you know, your
frontal cortex just takes a lunch.
>> Your brain got to the point where you're
you're just not reasoning.
>> This is actually changing who you are,
your values, your belief systems to the
point of 5 years down the road, you're
not the same person you once were.
>> Yeah. Even Kanye in his Sunday service,
there were certain types of music or
certain beats he wouldn't use.
>> Taylor Swift, Sabrina Carpenter.
>> I mean, that's not my generation. I
mean, and he probably has more similar
to I do cuz I think we're closer.
>> I'm just like, who are these people
again that are like
>> Matchbox 20, Three Doors Down?
>> I grew up on Britney Spears.
>> Nickelback.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I I listened to Nickelback
when I was Britney Spears, too. I was
all that kind of stuff. I mean, Justin
Bieber, he he's actually my age, so he
came out when I was a teenager, but I
wasn't I wasn't a believer.
>> I feel pretty old now.
>> I'm thinking more listened to anything
like that, right?
>> Oh, not at all. I'm thinking more of a
Metallica.
I've done I've done Metallica.
You're a little more hardcore. Oh, yeah.
>> You're not You're not Taylor Swift kind
of a person. You're not a Swifty.
>> No, no. You were you like insane clown
posi or anything like that?
>> No, that was uh too soft.
>> Too soft.
>> That was too soft back then. Yeah.
>> Whoa.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. We're thinking more of a
>> you know, Prince Riot and all this kind
of
>> you more like death metal stuff.
>> Uh not to the extreme, you know, like
heavy heavy heavy, but yeah, it was
pretty pretty rock and roll. We can say,
>> you know.
>> So, Abdel,
>> y
>> you're a health professional.
>> Yes. You've studied music on the brain
pretty in depth. It's kind of become
your passion project. That's why you're
here to talk about Taylor Swift, you
know, how does it affect your brain? I'm
sure you've looked into her music. I'm
just kidding.
>> But uh but yeah, how did you get into
it? And then like let's talk about music
on the brain.
>> Yeah. So, uh I mean it's been many
years. I did my masters in health
education and wellness um about 20ome
years ago. uh I do have a background in
nursing though that's not related
completely in the health side we can say
but I started studying of parts of the
brain and mainly it all began because I
was trying to see how actually the devil
actually dominates the mind
>> gotcha
>> that's the whole point in 2 Corinthians
4 verse 3 and 4 says but even if our
gospel is veiled it is veiled to those
who are perishing whose minds the god of
this age has blinded m blinded.
>> Yeah. Who do not believe less the light
of the gospel, the glory of Christ
should shine on them. And this is where
we start tying all together with health,
science, and the Bible. Because what the
word is actually using as blinded. That
is exactly how the brain responds every
time we either hear certain rhythm, we
hear certain music. Now research has
gone even way beyond of what we
understood as far as frequency and this
is just it just blows your mind which we
might not even have time to go into it
but we know that there's even certain
frequencies that can be used
>> interesting
>> of how it can damage our neurons. We
know our neurons communicate all by
electricity one neuron to another and
because there are not all the neurons
are completely attached but we know
there are certain u amino acids
different hormones um that actually make
those neurons be able to communicate one
with the other. You know, it's it's
interesting that you mentioned that like
certain music can actually, you know,
mess up with your your brain or mess
your brain up because I'm I'm helping
with a um it's the Nedley depression
anxiety recovery program.
>> It's a Dr. Netley's program and we run
it at our church and so I'm a certified
small group facilitator and he had in
one of his recent presentations he
actually talks about this that from a
scientific medical point of view
syncopated music actually is is a factor
that uh could cause or or worsen
depression and anxiety. And so actually
as a healing tool he he tells people you
need to listen to certain classical
music
>> to actually heal the brain from
depression.
>> Oh yeah.
>> So it's really a powerful tool for one
way or the other.
>> Now
there's been a lot more studies as far
as anapestic for example. So anapestic
anapex is actually a term used by Dr.
Diamond. Uh Dr. Diamond has done a lot
of research, John Diamond,
>> a lot of research on music and the
effect of the brain on that on that
sense. So an apastec is a term that he
actually did and
is the term actually comes from um when
you're writing poetry for example that's
the word anapestic where it comes from.
So he's applying this term anipestic as
far as the rhythm
>> got
>> that is applied in the music.
>> Okay.
>> So what's anestic? Well, it's two short
unstressed beats that follow a long
stress beat. For example,
now when you listen to music, just about
90% of the music that you hear will have
or will follow that type of a rhythm.
Um, it goes into you can have the two
with a with a strong one, you can have
the
So, it's always following a specific
type of a rhythm, but there's always uh
a one, two that is really strong. Okay.
Uh or two, three, the third one being
very strong.
>> And this is like this is called
syncopation as well, right? Is that
>> it's kind of like syncopation. Yeah.
Some people will call it syncopation.
John Diamond calls it anapestic rhythm.
I mean, the first thing that came to
mind was um
>> We Will Rock You by Queen.
>> Oh. Oh.
Oh, that's so true.
>> But I I've heard of this concept before
and I guess this is what Dr. Nedley is
talking about as well that it causes
stress to the brain whereas classical
music is supposed to like relax the
brain. Not that there's like literally
>> throw out 90% of the music and only
listen to classical. I mean, I'm sure
there's more genres than just classical
that we can listen to. Um, you know,
it's not like that's the the holy music
or something, but but but I I I see the
point that,
>> um, I mean, this is coming from multiple
voices from the medical field that this
might not actually be the best thing to
listen to. And
>> I mean, it's not even just, you know, we
will rock you or rock music or anything
like that. It's in most pop music, too,
right?
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah. uh you find this type of
a rhythm in rock music, Christian
contemporary music, uh pop music,
>> rap uses the type of a rhythm. I mean,
>> just about everything out there um will
actually have this type of a rhythm. Of
course, you have classical and you have
hymns and you have all this type of
music that does not follow a type of
syncupation or anapastic as Dr. and John
Diamond mentions but just about almost
all contemporary
uh world music we can say right
>> uh follows that type of a of a beat. Now
what he mentions is just extremely
uh I find fascinating
>> because he says this type of a rhythm or
this type of anapistic rhythm it causes
a switching of the brain
>> and we say what's the switching of the
brain?
>> So this is what he says the stop
anapistic beat found in much modern
music especially rock and certain forms
of Christian contemporary music causes a
phenomenon called switching of the
brain. The switching occurs when the
symmetry between the right and the left
hemisphere is destroyed.
>> So now he's going into the real science
of it.
>> So So wait, cuz we need both hemispheres
to function. So he's saying there's
literally no connection because it
sounds to me like you would just die if
there's no connection left.
>> Exactly. What it's doing is actually
there's no communication between one
neuron and the other.
>> So it disrupts all that communication.
So it causes switching which is what Dr.
Prail uh is actually uh mentioning. It
causes there's so much stress going on.
When that stress gets to a level uh so
high in our brain, it just stops
communicating and saying it's going into
a safe mode. We can say and say, "Wait a
minute, you know, I'm going to back off
here. Uh I don't know what's going on
with my brain." That's where all this
firing neurons actually there's no
communication.
>> Does it switch to like one side or the
other? Because I think, correct me if
I'm wrong, I think one side of the brain
is more logical and one side is more
like creative and emotional, right?
>> Yes. Um h and it's it all gets connected
right because we have the frontal the
the size we have the lyictive system the
occipital
>> all the eventually has to be connected
to be able to have all the certain
feelings we know feelings and all that
goes as we mentioned right right into
our limbistic system
>> um
>> that's where uh the emotions and when we
hear a type of a music you know we feel
oh that's so elevating or
>> or we feel the emotion of ah I want to
go and uh hit something when we hear
something very strong
>> that's actually overpassing
>> all of the over all of our loads we have
no control of it this is what Dr. John
Diamond is actually saying and he says
this disynchronization produces a stress
in the body.
>> Gotcha.
>> Which can manifest as a reduced work
performance, learning disabilities,
behavioral issues in children, and
general feeling of malice and fatigue in
adults.
>> So technically we might say, well yeah,
when I hear the music it's just an
effect, maybe a temporary effect, right?
I just hear it and I turn it off and I'm
okay. M
>> but no actually the disruption can be so
bad and the stressful and the stress in
our minds can be so permanent that it
starts conducing and creating a damage
in our brain. That's the prefront uh
sorry that's the lyic system right which
is like the part of the brain that sits
behind the pre prefrontal cortex
>> once it overpasses the primitive brain
all these things they lose control we
really we reduce self-control we had it
heightens an emotional response it
weakens moral discernment increase
suggestability
>> and it creates an emotional experience
that feels spiritual and but
disconnected from the person clear
reasoning worship so
>> interesting
>> what Dr. Richard is actually saying here
um is once all this switching and that
we've been talking about right and all
this bypass of the prefrontal cortex the
primitive brain
this is the disconnection what happens
on that disconnection and this is what
he's saying it's just that reduces the
self-control it heightens emotional
response again because it goes into the
lyic system yeah right now we're now
we're functioning by emotion now we're
functioning Oh, I feel this way.
>> Right? When we hear a good song, oh,
that song is just bringing me so close
to God. Now, is it really because it's
worship song or is it really because
it's a feeling? It's an emotion that is
taking you right there.
>> It just overpass your your frontal
cortex.
The worship, you know, most people might
say, "Oh, yeah, I worship and I worship
God from the heart." Yeah, but the heart
is just a muscle, right? It's not really
uh it doesn't have any brain. Everything
is happens in the brain. Everything. So,
is it really changing your life? Is it
really that music getting you closer to
God
>> or is it leaving you in the same area?
Or is it even pushing you back? You
might not even notice, right? Uh from
some of the stuff that we hear
>> but the part that the Dr. Richard is
actually saying once that goes into the
lyic system it passes our our prefrontal
cortex now we're just functioning by an
emotion so
>> same system that will release those
endorphins and kelins
>> so that when you do get exposed to those
very emotional experiences
it reinforces it and causes habits to
form because
>> those things are uh like opiates
you know, they cause
>> a feel-good sensation that your body
enjoys. And so it's like, well, I like
that. And everything your body
essentially likes brainwise, it tries
tries to figure out how to get more of.
>> And so it says, okay, that stuff feels
good. How do we get more of that? So
whatever you were doing to get that,
>> your body says, let's repeat that
experience.
>> And that's essentially what's happening,
you know, with lots of entertainment.
And so you go into this, it's
essentially like getting a fix.
>> Yeah. This is why actually I'm glad you
mentioned that because uh Joshua elites
uh Joshua leads uh on that book of the
power of the sound, he mentions the same
thing is the opioids when they're
experienced often enough can be
addicting and the listener seeks for a
high again.
>> And he says this is why listeners tend
to move from less to harder music.
>> And that's what I experienced when I was
younger. I remember my introduction to
music came through my dad because he was
a music lover and first he would buy me
like CDs like Britney Spears and there
was a Dutch band called Direct that was
kind of like punk rock and stuff but
then I remember and he would listen to
classical rock so I got into classical
rock and then I remember hearing
photograph by Nickelback super super
popular song but it was more like a
catchy radio rock song. Well, then I
looked into what else Nickelback had and
it started getting darker and darker and
darker to the point where it was almost
there was one song that's almost like
metal and then I got into Metallica. So,
you know, I I relate to this and I think
it is a thing then and then I was like I
don't want Britney Spears just like
whatever that is. I want Metallica or
something.
>> Yeah. Green Day, all those kind of
things, you know?
>> Uh yeah, that's probably what happened
to me too, right? I started listening to
some of the more uh upbeat Christian
contemporary music and it just kept
leading until you listen to Queen's Riot
and Metallica and you know all these
>> different artists which was heavy metal
and then everything else I was like ah
that's for CC's you know that's that was
my thing oh that's too soft like already
you need something way stronger
>> but it's interesting because I actually
had friends and and my brother had some
friends that they were into the music
but they were cutting themselves. They
were dressed in black, goth, depressed,
>> you know, and it's like you would
wonder. I mean, I do think that people
who are depressed and stuff like that,
they will start being attracted to music
that kind of acknowledges their
depression, which should tell you why
you probably shouldn't be listening to
that. But I also think that definitely
it can worsen it or it can, you know,
>> initiate it.
>> Initiate it. Yeah. Not that this music
immediately makes you depressed, but I
think if you listen to it long enough,
you're going to feel a little more down,
a little bit more dark.
>> Absolutely.
>> Yeah. Absolutely. And and the research
has I mean it it just confirms it. Every
study, it just reconfirms that, you
know, as long as you keep listening to
it, the effect on your brain will be a
lot greater, right? And you will end up
I mean there's no doubt researches
>> shows time after time that you will end
up anxiety depressed and with many other
diseases because once your neurons which
functions everything in your body
>> right
>> everything uh it gets disrupted you're
going to have a lot of diseases for
example people say no I listen to music
just to work out because it's going to
make me stronger
>> right right uh or it gives me that extra
push when I'm you know finishing that
on that marathon or whatever I'm doing.
>> Research has shown that is completely
the opposite.
>> Oh wow.
>> It actually makes your muscles weaker
because of the same disruption that is
occurring in our brain. If you're
putting your brain in that stress or
your your body is going to react to what
your brain is actually doing and your
your bo your brain goes to a stress your
body will go into a stress your muscles
are going to a stress and saying I'm
exhausted I'm tired and research have
shown that yes the hard music high
rhythm or even loud music will actually
make that stress in your brain and your
muscles actually get weaker. So instead
of listening to uh well I would
recommend not listening to anything when
you're doing exercise just spend that
time think of God you know that's what I
try to do think of verses just try to
you know have that communication um and
if you're doing very intense workout
just don't listen to anything you're
actually getting weaker
>> not only as you're exercising but the
the research shows also that time for
recuperation for your muscles takes a
lot longer because your body is still in
a stress
>> lineh. Mhm.
>> So
>> interesting.
>> We're thinking, oh yeah, no, we're still
thinking music is going to pump me up,
>> right?
>> No, it's not pumping you up. It's going
different effect.
>> If I used to ride, I ride a lot of
mountain bike. And back in the days,
that's what I used to do.
>> Um, now I don't listen to anything.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, uh, I'm 51 years old, but I
still ride.
>> But I actually feel stronger now than I
did before. And I'm you know we're not
going to go into all the details but uh
>> but it it has helped it has helped at
least in my life
>> you know I used to teach a class in uh I
guess it was like you know Christian
film making like teaching teaching
students how to do uh advertisements or
or other social media videos and I was
actually wanting them to understand
what music to put to your video. And so
I made them close their eyes and I said,
"Now I'm gonna play some tracks." There
was no lyrics to it. I said, "I want you
to close your eyes and listen and tell
me what what you imagine when you listen
to this and what emotions you have."
>> Yeah. And there's a variety because if
you just take away the lyrics of any
song and you just have that, you know,
you're going to have like, oh, I'm I'm
imagining that we're like in a forest
and it's dark and there's like it's like
a horror movie and it's creepy and now
this one is is angry and we're maybe at
a boxing match and we're punching each
other in the face, you know, and this
one is like a love song. So really the
lyrics, yeah, they they share a message,
but the music shares as much of a
message as the lyrics do.
>> Oh yeah, absolutely. And and that's the
biggest effect because most people when
I was growing up, most people would say,
well, you know, this song is is bad
because of the lyrics that it had, you
know, the the words and all that. But
and this one is we might say, oh, it's
good because it has words that are
positive,
>> right?
>> But when we look at the effect of the
actual music,
uh we don't need words to actually make
the effect that music can do to our
brain. It's not the words that actually
make the effect. Words can add to the
music and have either a positive effect
or a very negative effect, but the words
actually do not have to be included in
the actual music to affect the brain.
>> I mean, think about it. If you have a
heavy metal song and you like, I love
Jesus,
like that's a little bit weird. It's
like, okay, I don't know if you really
love Jesus cuz you're like shouting
screo at Jesus, you know? Um, and and
yeah, if you hear it with the lyrics,
you'll be like, man, that guy is angry.
And it's like, no, but I love Jesus. So,
you know, it's it's and and thinking
about it, Satan in the Bible in Isaia, I
think it's Isaiah 28 or Ezekiel 14, one
of those two that talk about Satan
before he fell, he had he had musical
components to him. So, he's like the
mastermind of music. So, why if he's the
deceiver, why wouldn't he just use all
of it?
>> It's actually the reverse. It's Ezekiel
28. Ezekiel 28. Thank you. Thank you.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And and Ezekiel 28, right, where
is it's talking about probably that what
a lot of theologians believe that of uh
that creation of of Lucifer, which he
was created probably within the music
effect, right? Um so we know that if
somebody knows about music, it's
definitely Satan. I mean, it's
>> absolutely
>> it's definitely Satan. and he knows
exactly
um I believe of how to target, what to
target to actually make a confusion. But
>> we can see more and more all the
research that just keeps coming out of
the effect of music on the brain. It's
just incredible right now.
>> Um I have another quote here from uh
this is a neurologist uh Richard Neil
Deermire. Um he says when music is loud
and rhythmic the prefrontal cortex can
be bypassed and the primitive brain
areas take over.
>> Mhm.
>> So thinking again right um our
prefrontal cortex uh cortex the
reasoning the judgment the self-control
our spiritual discernment.
>> Yeah. And the prefrontal cortex is the
frontal part of the frontal lobe. Yeah.
Everything right. So everything we hear
words, music, any message, anything
>> supposed to go through our frontal
frontal cortex, right? That's
that's where we start thinking okay I
had an example actually I put the words
here um
of this is the women's conference that
happened from
Sarah James and this was on this year
actually 2025
>> it says boots on the ground uh wizard go
them bangers alive in the building. I'll
dance by my
well, she said damn self.
>> Let your body move. Sipping on
moonshine, fire barrel rolling. I'm
going to get behind that thing girl.
>> So now imagining if I were to stand at a
conference
>> and just read these words, what would
people think? Like
>> they think you're crazy.
>> They will definitely say you're crazy.
This is a woman's conference that
actually occurred uh now in in 2025.
This is a Christian
>> what
>> women's conference
>> and the song was boots in the ground.
>> Who wrote it?
>> This was a song.
>> This is a song that was actually sung as
the introductory
in the women's conference and you can
look it up. Now, if I were to say the
words, just reading those words, they
will definitely kick me out of of the
stage and say, "Hey, you're crazy. Get
down." But when you look at the video
and the music is playing, you see people
just shouting, singing like, "Oh yeah,
>> why why I'm bringing this up?" Because
music has the effect again
>> that is just once again what doctor is
saying, it just overpasses the brain.
You have no reasoning.
>> If if I just put you in a good rhythm,
>> hey, we can all sing along. And you see
people there like you anybody with a
conscious mind with something some
rationale will say wait a minute this is
way out of line. This is completely
wrong.
>> But since the music is playing and it's
bam bam bam.
>> Hey it's all okay. We're all shouting.
We're all singing. We're having a fun
time.
>> We don't care. So
>> I can if if I put you in a state where I
can play you a good rhythm. You feel all
happy. Well, I can tell you anything you
want. And that's what we can see now
with this, especially all the modern
music. They're telling you things that,
oh, well, you know, somebody murder or
even to the extreme, you know, go into
your bedroom and do something that you
shouldn't be doing, which can be fatal
to your life. And hey,
how how is this possible? How it people
get to even sing the songs because
they're not even realizing. You get to
the point, your brain got to the point
where
>> you're you're just not reasoning.
>> What you're hearing is just coming out
to your brain. You don't even understand
what you're actually saying. And it's
very dangerous. And we seen very bad
effects from actually the fact of music.
>> You see this all the time when when a
popular piece of music comes out,
especially for in something in
animation, you know, all the little kids
are singing it and they don't even know
what they're singing at all.
>> Yeah. Like Frozen.
>> They're just singing. Yeah. Frozen.
>> No. right, no wrong, no rules for me.
I'm free. And you're like, "Wait a
minute." Oh, no, no, no. You have rules,
buddy.
>> Yeah.
>> But that message is being put in their
brain and it just bypass, you know, your
frontal cortex just takes a lunch. I
mean, essentially,
>> oh yeah,
>> it's checked out. It's it's like done.
So, it just goes in and next thing you
know, they're singing it all the time
and it's like you take messages like
that, you put them in generations of
people. And then you come 20, 30, 40, 50
years later and it's no wonder that
every generation increasingly is more
agnostic, more atheist, you know, all of
that because it's like, well, don't need
God, don't need rules.
>> Yeah. It's like planting little seeds,
you know. Yeah. And I wonder because the
Bible does talk about the um,
>> you know, uh, way beholding we become
changed, you know, beholding Christ, we
become changed, but you could apply that
to the other side as well. And in fact,
we did a we recorded a show recently
with Dr. Eric Walsh about music on the
brain and he uh or maybe actually I I
put it in a show about Sabrina
Carpenter. We can probably put a link in
the description. There was a doctor who
talked about mirror neurons which we've
talked about many times before in this
show, but he specifically applied it to
music actually and and he talked about
it as well that yeah, when you listen to
this kind of music, your mirror neurons
take effect. meaning your brain if it's
seeing something, hearing something,
it's going to think that it's doing it
itself. So I could see how yeah this
probably with the prefrontal cortex the
the frontal loes shut down your
reasoning powers turn off your mirror
neurons are going that this is probably
actually changing who you are your
values your belief systems to the point
of 5 years down the road taking in all
this media you're not the same person
you once were. Oh, yeah.
>> I sat down with three young ladies
recently um doing a a seminar
>> and
uh I don't remember. I think they're the
ones that brought it up. K-pop Demon
Hunters.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, I was like, "Okay, let's talk about
it." I was like, "Did you know this was
in the in the the film?" They're like,
"I've watched it three times."
>> Yeah.
>> No, didn't didn't get it.
>> Wow. So you can easily
condition people or put messages in
there and they just essentially have no
idea
>> that that's what they're taking in.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's going in.
>> And uh Scotty did a presentation years
ago at a Christian university. We
actually have a clip of this in one of
our seminars. The next film I'm going to
show you and and this is a clip kind of
that was in uh our film that we had been
passing out on the Sabbath when we went
to Southern University and gave this
talk at Southern University.
You'll see how many people in our even
conservative colleges are affected by
these films. I want to ask a quick
question. I have seen this movie
probably 20 times, maybe more. This was
one of my favorite films.
Yeah.
>> How many people in this room have seen
this movie?
>> Look at how many hands just went up.
>> Can somebody tell me in this movie where
they speak about God?
>> You got one person.
>> What scene?
>> One person.
>> All of you people raised your hand and
only one person told me when they talk
about God. The power of this medium.
Just like what Tommy showed you
yesterday is the information goes into
your head within 30 seconds. You stop
thinking about the information. Your
brain flips from your left side of your
brain into your right side of your
brain. You react to everything
emotionally and literally all of the
words are just imprinted onto your
brain. They know this. That's why we
wanted to show you about the advertising
industry. We wanted to show you that
there's businesses that know this
information and they make millions of
dollars with it.
And if these people are not on God's
side,
whose side are they on?
There is no middle ground. If these
people are not being used by God,
it's very, very possible that Satan is
using them instrumentally
to bring us away from God.
Here's a clip of the film that they talk
about God.
>> Our fathers were our models for God. If
our fathers bailed, what does that tell
you about God?
>> No, no, I don't.
>> Listen to me. I have to consider the
possibility that God does not like you.
Never wanted you. In all probability, he
hates you. This is not the worst thing
that can happen.
>> Is it?
>> We don't need him.
>> If we don't agree, we damnation, man.
Redemption. We are God's unwanted
children. SO BE IT.
>> LISTEN, you can run water over your hand
and make it worse. Or look at me.
>> Or you can use vinegar to neutralize a
burn.
>> Please let me have it. Please.
>> First, you have to give up. First, you
have to know, not fear, know that
someday you're going to die.
>> You don't know how this feels.
>> It's only after we've lost everything
that we're free to do anything.
>> That's
that's the incredible. I mean, because
as Christians, you know, the the whole
idea is to walk closer to God, right?
>> You know, to depart, as it says, right?
let's depart from the things of of this
world. Uh we're constantly trying to
have a godly life. That's the whole
idea.
>> We can hear this music. We can watch all
these things and not realize and
if we were actually have the conscious
if these things were actually be
rationale in our as we know as in our
frontal cortex,
>> right?
>> We would definitely say no. Mhm.
>> You know, at that very moment, we hear
something, no, that this is wrong. I'm
either going to turn it off. I'm not
going to stop, you know, stop listening
to this type of music or whatever. But
the devil has been once again so
enticing, so deceiving.
>> Yep.
>> That just as the research shows, it just
passes our frontal cortex and we're not
reasoning for the things that we're
hearing. We're just it passes. It goes
into our emotion. Our emotion makes us
feel good. There's a release of dopamine
and it makes you, oh, this is nice. I
like the rhythm. I like this these
things. And you're not realizing of,
well, yeah, I want you to drink alcohol,
do drugs, uh, be with this woman, you
know, lay in bed, do all these all these
kind of things. And you're like, wait a
minute, this is completely opposite of
what God actually tells us. And then
eventually if you if you might accept
those lifestyle choices, it's like where
did it come from? Well, it's all the
media you consume by beholding become
changed. And that might not even mean
that somebody's like, "Oh, I'm a devout
Christian and I'm not going to sleep
with 10 different women and do drugs."
You might not. But but even the the the
idea of like we're on our journey to
God, right? Like we are heaven bound as
they say in the old hymns. And Paul
talks about that we have to run the race
as if there's one prize to take the
crown. And so, you know, when you're
training for a sports event, man, you
are on it. You are giving it your all.
You are disciplined. And that's what
he's referring to. And so, we don't even
want to take one step backwards on this
walk with God. If this is hindering us,
then then God's like, I've got something
better for you. deceiver. The deceiver
is out there and he's trying to tell you
that this is life. It actually leads to
death.
>> Mhm. Yeah. Yeah. Um I mean the Satan
Satan is doing everything he can. We
know that.
>> Um
>> Yeah.
>> And you know again
I I talk about this and and I try to
mention as much as I can because I feel
I went through it,
>> right?
>> You know I I grew up consider a
Christian home, you know, going to
church, doing all the what we would say
the right things. But when I put all
together in my life, you know, when I
started listening to sometimes it was a
Christian singer
>> um but one thing just kept leading into
another
>> because yeah, you can start listening
well this contemporary music but I like
it. Well, this is no different than what
has been playing out there. So, it's the
same rhythm. It's the same the same
thing. So we get so accustomed into our
brain that that's probably how I ended
up listening little by little to
you know Punjabi uh
>> all these older artists just little by
little
>> but when I look back in my life I
started noticing it was probably within
that time that little by little I also
had no interest anymore in church. I I
have no desire to pray. I have no desire
to open the Bible. I have no desire. And
as I kept growing older and older, it
got to that point where, well, yeah,
church is has no meaning,
>> you know, I I really don't care about
anything on Christianity level. Um,
>> and it was eventually until
through everything I started studying
and and there were numerous things that
happened in my life that made me realize
like, wait a minute, something is wrong
here.
When those things started happening, I
still would listen to some contemporary
music, some, you know,
>> right right kind of the pop way of
contemporary music. And some people
would say would tell me, you know, maybe
you should stop listening to that type
of music,
>> right?
>> But I was say, it's okay. You know,
that's not going to have in my mind that
doesn't have any effect on me.
>> But it was not actually until I stopped
listening to that music
>> that I truly believe that the Bible just
became real to me.
>> Amen. Wow.
>> The Bible really I mean the word of God
actually became real and for that time I
did not know you know what was the path
I needed to take um
what are the things you know what
what church should I go to I had no idea
>> you know I I have grown up in a church
but it was not actually until I sat down
and studied for myself
>> what really does the Bible say is
there's is there a church out there that
actually
talks about what the Bible actually
says, you know, that keeps God's
commandment, that talks about uh being
close to God by justification by faith
or righteousness by faith, all these
things that, you know, grace, mercy, all
the things that that we truly know.
And it was not until I sat down and I
left everything behind that those things
became real in my life.
>> Amen. Um, that's when I knew the devil
was really tricking my mind. Um, and
it's not until then that I can say once
I leave everything behind, okay, now
that I get a clear mind, now I can see
all the effects that actually that had
in my life during all that past time,
>> right? Uh, I'm not perfect, of course. I
started studying different things of
what type of things either in our daily
life, things that we eat, we drink, we
see affects our brain, our watch, right?
>> Uh how does that affect our brain in a
way
>> that we have actually no control of it?
>> And that was kind of the how it all
started in this topic and started going
pretty deep of especially in the music
part. Gotcha.
>> Music in the brain. Um so music was
always evolving in our house.
>> Um being on that side of the music of uh
you know Petra back on the Christian we
can say as a striper I don't know
somebody might remember striper but you
know you look at a picture of the
striper and you look at Cinderella or
Bojobi it looked just about the same. Um
so all those kind of artists were um you
know we're talking about 30 years ago
that's what I liked back then but I knew
that in my life it also it had an effect
>> right
>> and that's how kind of that journey
later on I started making sense to
everything I started studying on music
and the brain and I started putting
everything together of maybe why did I
started falling back and got so
disinterested on the Bible not wanting
to pray. And it got to a point where I
will actually say, "Yeah, I'm not
technically a Christian."
>> You know,
>> yeah, it's interesting that you bring
these things up because, you know, we we
I'm sure most Christians don't or most,
but some Christians refuse to listen to
to worldly music, but I I kind of
started questioning this myself when I
when I saw certain Christian musicians
and I was like, but there's not much of
a difference in how they dress, for
example. And it's and it's like and and
I think it has to do with the marketing
machine that's backing them up is that
there's this expectation to dress a
certain way to have certain album covers
that really it's very much unfortunately
a a form of like looking to like
pointing to self instead of pointing to
Jesus which not all like there are some
that are mainstream Christian musicians
that don't do that but
>> I I have thought about that now I've
been like yeah like that's it it's made
me think through these things. Mhm.
>> I think a second thing that is that your
theology shapes your lifestyle,
>> right?
>> So if your theology is one that
kind of says
those are external things, they don't
really matter,
>> right?
>> God doesn't really care.
>> It's not that important. You know, God
loves me anyway and I can kind of just
live my life the way I want.
>> The once saved, always saved concept.
>> It won't, you know, then that's how
you're going to live.
>> Yeah. And that that's on that point
that's where actually I just started
seeing a lot of changes you know how do
we get to think that way because uh we
know the word of God tells us something
completely different
>> of how a Christian life should be right
>> you know we should be depart from the
world we should be more leaning to
Christ you know looking for the better
things of this world and how do we get
to lean into the other side of why the
things of the world attracting me so
much there has to be something that the
devil and that's you know where all this
topic you know flur up is something that
the devil actually does to our mind that
it just confuses us so much that we get
to a point where we cannot detect what's
right and what's wrong
>> because our minds are just so blooded
with so much other things that we just
get to that point where I don't know
what's right I don't know what's wrong
>> and we're walking in a line like I know
I should do this but I just don't have
that much interest and I don't even
notice that I'm actually walking in the
wrong path,
>> right? Um that's where you know all
these things and when I I tied it up to
Revelation which is kind of the book
where um I started studying a lot um
trying to put all this together
especially towards the end times how the
devil actually tries to control and we
see the part of worship uh
>> all these minds and all these things
>> how then the devil is actually
controlling us in a way that we don't
get to even realize where we're at.
>> Yeah. Because revelation 13 and mark of
the beast, if you understand where it
is, right here behind the forehead, it's
part of brain you use for worship to
make decisions where your morality is.
>> So if you're constantly affecting and
changing your brain when you listen to
certain music or watch certain movies,
it's reshaping your brain. That's
dangerous to then where you are being
programmed to eventually take the mark
of the beast and not accept the seal of
God. Mhm. Yeah. We can see all these
symbols, right, that the book of
Revelation actually kind of gave us. And
I truly believe they're not there just
to be there for any special meaning.
There has to be a purpose.
>> Um, and we know that people are not
going to be walking with an actual seal
right in the in our forehead. So there
has to be a symbolic and much deeper
than what we probably are accustomed to
here. Um, I think this is where that
topic where you put science, health, and
the Bible all three together, it just
starts blowing your mind what the Bible
is actually trying to tell you.
>> Definitely.
>> Um,
>> that's where all this topic just is so
interested. Um because you get to see
the the the Bible, the word of God in a
different spectrum and actually see what
the devil is trying to do on his end
trying to dominate uh our minds, our
lives, everything that we do in our
daily uh walk with Christ.
>> You know, um I actually wanted to share
a verse um because this is where all the
things kind of got started, right? Uh it
was on the book of revelation as you
mentioned and we find this verse on
revelation 12:9 and it says so the great
dragon was cast out that serpent of all
called the devil and Satan who deceives
the whole world he was cast to the earth
and his angels were cast out of him. M
>> and the reason this verse for me it was
so important it was to understand the
three ways that Satan will actually be
working on his end time. If we see it
has three names there in that verse
trying to describe one the same
individual.
>> We see dragon, we see serpent and we see
the devil and Satan.
>> Now some people might say well this is
not first, middle and last name right?
Yeah,
>> it's actually three different and we can
say three different powers that the
devil will actually be utilizing at the
end time to try to confuse people and
try to do his work on their lives.
>> Dragon, we can see it. Well, yeah,
that's a persecution power, right? We
read it all through the book of
Revelation. The dragon is continually
persecuting that woman. And we find it
right in Revelation 12. persecuting that
woman constantly, constantly. Even all
the way through the verse 17 of of
chapter 12, we still find that that
dragon is persecuting the woman and and
it has two specific characteristics,
right? Those that keep the law of God
and have the testimony of Jesus.
>> Yeah. And the woman in Ephesians, it's
symbolic of a church, God's church, his
pure his pure church and also there's a
a false church in Revelation.
>> False church. Yeah. Which talks him in
Revelation chapter 18. Right now, we
say, "Okay, dragon. Yeah. Uh that's a
persecuting power. Serpent. Where do we
find the serpent? Well, we find the
serpent from the very beginning.
>> Genesis 3. Deceiving power.
>> Deceiving power, right? Um and we have
of course the devil and Satan. And
that's more as an accuser.
>> We find that in in throughout the Bible
how the devil is constantly trying to
accuse us in everything that we do.
>> Zechariah 3, I believe, as well.
>> Yep. Now, serpent, right, which is the
one that that we're looking at here, um,
deceiving power. But, you know, you
think about it, what actually made Eve
just not only walk there, but have that
conversation. We know she would, she had
no sin.
>> She was a perfect being. She can talk
directly with God. We know that walk
actually uh God will actually walk with
them in the Eden in the Garden of Eden.
So, how was she still able to fall?
>> Right?
>> I mean, the words of that serpent, which
we know who who it is, right? It's
staying right there. The de that devil,
that Satan, it had to be so deceiving,
>> so enticing,
so attractive
that she would say, "Yeah, that that
does make sense." I mean, in in the
words that he will use, it just blew her
mind off. Like I mean he went straight
all the way to I'm going to overpass. We
can say your frontal loaf because your
frontal loaf is the place that we know
we can create judgment. We can make the
distinctions. We we can
>> you know analyze all these things. So
there had to be something that it can
overpass or bypass her frontal loaf, go
all the way to the what we know now is
the Limbix system where you can actually
just run by your emotions, your
feelings. It had to reach all the way
back there to say, "Oh, this is not so
bad."
>> I've never considered that before, but
it makes perfect sense because Eve had a
brain just like us.
>> Just like us. And so yeah, like if if
her frontal lobe was working and was
functioning well, then clearly she would
have said, "No, I can reason through
this with my frontal lobe. This is not
how this worked."
>> Do you think Absolutely. The thing I
think about is
>> prior to that, what did she have to
reason through?
>> What's a lie? If you're Eve, what's a
lie?
>> She'd never been lied to.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. She'd never had to come to a
point where she made a choice on
information.
>> It's always been a one-way
communication. Like everything you're
being told is from God or one of the
angels or something. It's always been
right.
>> Yeah.
>> She'd never been presented with
information that wasn't right.
>> Mhm.
And how are you able to discern that?
>> Yeah.
>> Right. How was she able to discern that?
>> But she knew from God. God said, "Do not
eat of this tree."
>> Which is the only way. And that's why
you get back to that idea of
>> you have to trust the word of God. Yeah.
>> Because that's the only thing she had to
stand on.
>> Yeah.
>> So she had that small bit of information
to reason with. You know, when this
other information was presented, she
could have said no cuz God said this.
>> But like you said,
>> you know, she opened the door basically
to start talking to the snake first of
all. And then you know it must be that
maybe her reasoning powers were shut off
or maybe she just like gave in enough
that it went you know directed to the
liyic system or she reasoned and said
I'm reasoning for Satan. I don't know
but something happened in the brain.
>> Yeah. Some something definitely had to
happen. Yeah.
>> One way I've I've thought about this
before is that he's putting a positive
spin on it.
>> Yeah. So at that point, everything they
had was provided to them like a gift.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Here's this beautiful garden.
Here's all these food. Here's all these
animals. Here's each other. Everything's
a gift.
>> Now,
he's coming out with this idea that
there's another gift, but God isn't
giving it to you.
>> That's super sinister, right? There's
some gift that God is withholding from
you.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Now, and and I bring this
verse and I tie it on to to Eve in the
garden because actually second
Corinthians actually talks about
something about what happened in the
garden and about the mind. And this is
where I find fascinating.
>> But I fear let somehow as the serpent
deceive if by his craftiness and watch
what it says. So your minds may be
corrupted from the simplicity that is in
Christ. M.
>> Mhm.
>> So
>> that's interesting.
>> Mind was corrupted.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> You're you're I mean according to
scripture there's some craftiness and
the mind is corrupted. So the question
is how does that happen?
>> Yeah.
>> Uh that's the thing you know that's
where I take it back to we don't know
exactly the whole conversation of what
actually happened. You know uh
>> we know we have bits and pieces but we
definitely don't have the whole
conversation. There had to be a lot more
of what Satan was actually telling Eve
at that very moment. Uh how was he
saying it? You know, we don't have the
full spectrum. But we we do have to
understand it had to be I mean it says
it right there. The serpent deceived
Eve. It had the words have to be
extremely enticing that so deceiving. So
so peaceful. So
>> had to be close to the truth.
>> Oh yeah. And I think 99% of it was
probably true, you know, when we think
about it,
>> right?
>> And it had to be in a way that she would
say, "Yeah, that kind of makes sense."
But what did the devil actually do to
her mind to actually get her to think
that way? Because if we are able to
process everything that we should
through our frontal loaf where we make
all those decisions, all our judgments,
everything that comes in through our
mind has to go through it and we make
that conscious decision, we will
actually realize and say wait a minute
no there's something wrong there's
something that is not right and I'm I'm
I'm
>> we you know on our own will actually
realize I'm starting to head in the
wrong path. I'm trying to think in the
wrong way. Our mind is just way more
powerful than we actually think.
>> Um, and we still don't understand the
full concept of our brains. I mean, it's
>> right,
>> it's just so complex. Um, so there had
to be so much that Satan was actually
working on Eve at that moment that we
just don't understand. But we're
beginning to understand because all the
things that we actually beginning to see
of the brain of how it functions how
music, media, entertainment, all these
things can actually damage our brain
>> which are things that are you know 10,
15 years ago. It was probably crazy to
say something like this. But research
keeps coming out and saying, "Yeah,
there are ways that actually
it can damage our frontal uh uh our
frontal loaf if we can say it can damage
our brain and Satan is utilizing a lot
of tools to actually make that happen."
>> What was the catalyst though? What
caused you to take that pause and say,
"I'm just not going to listen to this
for a while or maybe I shouldn't listen
to that." What was that catalyst?
Yeah, I think from
I know people would come and tell me,
you know, I'm praying for you. I'm
praying for you.
>> Um, not only from my family, but I had
friends that would actually tell me, you
know, I'm praying for you. Cuz I
>> I'm telling you, I got to a point where
I I really had no interest, you know, of
of the Bible and all that. And there
were certain things in life that
happened and it made me realize you know
maybe I should start looking for God. Um
during that time that's you know I was
still listening to that contemporary
music but I started opening the word of
God and really going into prayer and
slowly
>> more
I would say not slowly but I would say
in a very in a good pace we can say
>> right right
>> all that music I just started leaving
behind. How do I make that connection? I
don't know. I think the word of God just
really started acting in the heart and
saying, "Well, you're listening is just
wrong.
>> It's just wrong."
>> And it got to that point where I finally
just say, you know, it just had no
interest.
>> It really became to the point where I
just had no interest of listening to
that music. And if I would hear it, it
would be like, you know, I got to
realize
>> that's not good for me. That's just not
good for me. It's like um it's like
Moses or is it Elijah that it's it's
Elijah that God said it's in this still
small voice the stillness that I'm being
that I'm found. Yeah.
>> You know, it's the same thing as with
this. It's like where there's the whole
world is screaming at you and it's kind
of like
>> walking through this alley and and
there's just entertainment all around
you and and like people trying to get in
your face and being like, "Look at this.
Look at this." And then God is just like
come sit here in the quiet. And that's
eventually
when your heart starts to change and the
spirit works in your heart, you realize
that's where the peace is, the genuiness
is and that's becomes more attractive to
you than all everybody's, you know,
making all this noise around you from
the world.
>> Oh yeah. I think the closer we get to to
God and and to the word and we spend
more time in prayer,
he starts showing us things that, you
know, saying, "Hey, you should cut this
off from your life." You know,
>> uh when we, for example, I I always
relate to John chapter 15, which is one
of my favorite verses in the Bible. U
you know and it's God is asking is
pleading us to abide you know for us to
abide in him and him to abide in us just
as he abides with his father and his
father and him are one.
I truly begin to understand God wants to
be one with me
>> and I should do everything possible in
my Christian life
not all not by my power because these
things are not
>> I don't think I have the true power to
>> to say I have to discard everything on
this
>> right
>> but God gives us the power
for us to determine this is wrong for me
and I should leave this behind
>> y
>> and I truly think that the closer I just
began to walk with God. He just started
talking and saying, "These are the
things you have to leave behind. These
are the things you have to leave
behind."
>> Amen.
>> I mean, I made a lot of changes, not
only on the music side, but on the
nutrition side. Um because we know that
as well on the nutrition side, there's
plenty of things that we can it's a
whole another show that can take for
many hours of how food can really affect
your brain in extremely negative ways
that
>> you know research is just outstanding on
on all the things that are just coming
up and the effect of the brain. But
understanding of the deception of Satan,
of how he's truly trying to deceive us
in a way that we just don't even
comprehend and don't even realizing is
just very outstanding. And that's that's
probably where God has been taking me
and saying, "Hey, just talk about it."
You know, hopefully there's somebody out
there that can realize and say, you
know, I want to I want to walk closer
with God.
>> Maybe there's something here I should
probably, you know, leave behind. You
know, I I've always been interested. And
this is one of the singers I used to
listen when I was a lot younger. Right.
>> What What band is he from? Or is he just
Oh, of course I know Aerosmith. Yeah.
>> Uh was Steven Tyler, uh well-known music
artist, but he said rock music is the
strongest drug in the world.
>> There you go. Drugs, brain,
>> you know,
>> from the horse's mouth.
>> And it's all What does drug do to our
brain? Y
>> it's a complete disruption. Um and this
is someone that we all know. I mean it's
very well known. Um somebody knows about
music. I would say he's one of them.
>> Yeah. And he's at the top.
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> Absolutely.
>> So um we have another one from Donnie
Brewer. Donnie Brewer is one of the best
drummers. Probably some consider
probably the best drummer that has ever
existed.
>> What band is he from?
>> Uh actually he used to play uh different
bands but he used to play funk music.
That's actually how he became extremely
famous back in the days.
>> And this is what he says. We take the
kids away from their parents and their
environment to where their only reality
is the rhythm and the beat.
>> Yeah.
>> They know what they're doing.
>> Oh yeah. He's making the entire
connection what we've been talking right
of the rhythm, the beat, right?
>> How all disrupts the the mind, the
brain.
>> There's something in this people knew
>> Mhm. that it does to our minds.
>> They're they definitely understand the
power of the music that probably most of
us don't understand, but these people
lift it.
>> And it's amazing that all these authors,
I mean, we can find quote after quote of
all these different artists that are
just plainly telling us, hey, this is
bad. But
>> for somehow, it just hasn't clicked in
our mind. I think we are so accustomed
to it and our brains are pretty much
hopefully not too damaged that we don't
realize but have had a a pretty bad
effect that we just not realizing that
how bad it is.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Even Kanye in his Sunday service
there were certain types of music or
certain beats he wouldn't use.
>> He said, you know, it's it's not
appropriate or it would affect people
>> in a way he didn't want them to be
affected or in a negative way. So,
as somebody that understands music very
well.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. They they clearly
telling us and we just need to realize
it. I think that's that's the main
point. We need to realize that there is
power. There is power in the music and
it's not about the words. You know,
words does have a an influence on it,
but the music does have a complete
effect in our brain.